it's not like I go out a lot socially I
just don't do that but I was at a a
party a couple of weeks ago a birthday
party a birthday party for someone and I
didn't know a lot of people but you and
your lovely wife Thompson Bell were
there and uh I saw you guys and I was
with my wife we ended up spending a lot
of time together lovely dinner uh an
inner uh evening eating dinner together
is what happened
well we're out of time
uh chips next year yeah uh but yeah we
we have basically an impromptu double
date yeah which was fun and I wanted to
tell you then but I was nervous it might
trigger something for you that your wife
is so attractive
she's like really exceedingly attractive
what now okay
I was afraid if I told you that that you
would feel the way I feel when people
tell me that my wife is really
attractive because you and I are not so
attractive
so what I think what I'll keep it to me
no no no no I'm so attractive so when
people start telling me your wife's
beautiful but the third time they say it
all I'm hearing is you are so ugly yeah
how did you get her yeah a lopsided face
yeah that's it is funny how when people
I very lucky a very attractive wife and
people talk about it a little too much
too much I sort of start to feel like
yeah we're kind of evenly matched right
they're like no right yeah people would
be like oh my God we watch Frozen your
wife's voice your your nose is so big
and crooked that's what I hear but
I had that experience and I just want to
tell you I just really thought your wife
was attractive it was no comment on you
right so but now that you're seeing this
in this way uh-huh it's it's sounding
very much like a comment on me because
you're going way out of your way and now
my face feels she's so attractive yeah
yeah stop it okay
I don't want to hear this anymore okay
Annie's wife is also too attractive for
him yeah
lose you no it's all right yeah the
three of us the three of us something oh
my goodness yeah our wives need to go to
the optometrists
they should get a coupon together
they're they're really deep Soulful
women that look beyond the exterior yeah
is that what it is yeah yeah yeah
or they have Stockholm syndrome yeah
that's one of the two okay I have to say
I think you're the same way I noticed
like you keep yourself in pretty good
shape I try to you know I work out and I
think maybe that's okay my wife's up
here and I'm here but maybe by working
out all the time yeah you're definitely
inching closer and for real we were
eating dinner and I out of nowhere
because I I'm well documented I love
male bodies as I love women's bodies I
just love the human Farm
and so I happen to notice when we were
eating dinner I was like your chest is
really kind of protruding and what's
great about noticing men's bodies is you
can immediately touch I was like man are
you working out and I was feeling your
biceps and your triceps like nice delts
yeah I see hot women all the time I
can't manhandle them yeah but as soon as
I I noticed you had been Pumping Iron I
got in there and I felt everything I
wanted to feel yeah he did
it's probably more it's probably more
like the meat department at Ralph yeah
just checking out all the cuts I was I
spent 30 seconds probably feeling you
yeah right and it's normal everyone else
was fine with it yeah I wanted to see
what was happening with your wife but I
didn't yeah that's right just because
you don't do that we agreed we were
going to leave her out of it and stick
to my body and how I mean you didn't
feel Kristen either
no I didn't no right you're a gentlemen
yeah and I also didn't reach over and
feel you because I didn't want to and I
am if you want to set up a swinger thing
you should probably do it by email yeah
it's a great way to break the ice okay
because it could be a joke there's a
comedy show right yeah so by the time I
said I Wanda
get you and our wives together
I was just teasing unless you think
that's a good idea
[Applause]
if you don't think it's funny it's a
great idea I do have a place if not what
a ride